residents in the village of Shakira are
trying to put the past behind them in
May 2015 more than 20 children here died
of lead poisoning after drinking
contaminated water we took my son to the
hospital and they told us he had been
exposed to lead he later died we are now
very careful we hope we'll be able to
protect ourselves better in the future
uh Kalia the residents of Shakira have a
champion here a few hundred kilometers
away in Abuja activist Hamza Laval is
committed to fighting corruption in
Nigeria his initiative called follow the
money
monitors government spending and finds
out where the money really goes it then
publishes its findings Laval is
traveling to Shakira for him this visit
is about more than just cleaning up the
water how can we ensure that we can
still keep that momentum going beyond
Jos environmental cleanup and access to
health care services the activist
arrives to see things for himself
most families in Shakira make their
living from gold mining young people dig
deep holes in the ground hoping to
strike gold
they then crushed the order to extract
the precious mineral but the ore also
contains lead which is ground into dust
the toxic particles eventually find
their way into the water supply the
miners and their families are slowly
being poisoned the government is turning
a blind eye to the root causes
despite its promises to help and also
taking pictures of them and sharing this
information on Twitter and Facebook and
calling them to action and showing them
this evidence-based data the government
has kept its promise to build a new
health center it was built after the
number of lead poisoning cases began to
grow and more children began to die it
means that finally live
can be saved my child began to convulse
I've been bringing her here regularly
for treatment and now she's doing better
Homs at Laval is monitoring the whole
process although gold diggers are still
working the lead contaminated earth he's
happy about the health center you can
see family members come in to access
health care services for their children
under five years who have been who were
contaminated by lead poisoning now
receiving treatment and feeling much
better it's quite exciting for us
although little has been done to provide
alternative means of employment the
government says it will try to regulate
gold mining operations in Shakira
anti-corruption activists say they'll
make sure that doesn't remain an empty
promise